ん
[音楽]
ええええええ
こんにちは
はじめまして前本みゆです
私は皆さんと同じ上智大学の学生でフリーランスでちょこちょこモデルの仕事をし
ながら
させのブルーライフクリエイター
形でゆるくて楽しいエコライフ
というのを youtube やインスタグラムを通じていろいろと発信しています
皆さんはエコという言葉についてどういう風なイメージを抱きますか
私は昔はこう意識高いなぁとかあんまり
私には関係ないなーっていうふうに思っていました
今日はそんな私がエコというものを気にかけるようになったきっかけである
インドネシアという場所での経験
そして大学生にでもできるエコということで私が朝起きてから家を出る前までのこの
短い時間でやっている気軽にできるエコなことについて色々とお話ししていきたいと
おもいます
突然ですがみなさんインドネシアという国がどこにあるかご存知ですか
正解はここです
東南アジアにある島国なんですが私は父の仕事の都合で高校三年間をこのインドネシア
にある者がれたという首都で過ごしました
東南アジア最近はかなり腰早く旅行できるので皆さん入ったことはある方多いんじゃ
ないかなっていうふうに思うんですが
こんな感じです
皆さんのイメージよりもだいぶ発展して見えるんじゃないかなというふうに思うんです
が
かろうじて屋根はあるくらいの家から本当に数分も離れないところに40階建てくらい
の5つ星ホテルみたいなビルが並んでいたりとなかなかのカオスです
インドネシアに引っ越してからは毎日が驚きの連続でした
犬ねシアは赤道直下の国なので季節は他の2つ
武器か換気を
常夏なんですね
犬ね者の人口の9割以上はイスラム教信者なので
女性の多くがヒジャブという顔の日を出すなのですね
かぶっていて暑くても肌を出しません
てジャカルタが誇るギネス記録それは重体です
私の学校から家までだいたい車で20分ほどだったんですが武器になるとインフラが
整っていないので行成をしてしまうことがあるんですね
かつ渋滞なので頭もと20分くらいの道を一度4時間ぐらいかけて入らなきゃいけない
こともありました
たまに後者の体育館を洪水で浸水してしまったりと本当に日本ではなかなか考えられ
ないようなことが常に起きているというめまぐるしい状況でした
そして私が今まで暮らしてきていた世界っていうものがどれほど小さなものだった
かっていうのも日々日々
突きつけられているような感覚でした
そんな中で私にエコな行動というのを意識させてくれるきっかけになったことがひとつ
あります
それは担任の先生がホームルームの時間に見せてくれたある
日本のビデオです
そのビデオは環境保護団体グリーンピースによるものであるチョコレート菓子に使用さ
れているパームオイルという脂がインドネシアの森林破壊とウランルーターの絶滅に
つながっているということを伝えるものでした
オランウータンは実はインドネシア語でご覧は1
ブータンは森森の人という意味
私が暮らしていた犬ね試合に生息しています
ですがほらむーたんの住処である熱帯雨林は年々このような形でファームをいる畑に
するためにどんどん破壊
燃やされて言ってしまっていて今おらんぐーたんは絶滅の危機に瀕しています
私はこの動画で自分の生活が動物の舌別にこんなにも密接に関わっているんだという
ことを知って強い食を気
そんなパン王いるは食品や日用品のほとんどに含まれているんですが
きっと皆さん基金の子見ないですよね
ではショートリングまーがりん
界面活性剤植物油脂なんかだったらどうでしょうか
ファーもいるが実際に使われている時はこのような名称で表記されていることが
ほとんどです
私はこのグリーンピースの動画をきっかけに私が日々使っているものだったり食べて
いるものがどのように作られているのか
何でできているのかを意識して暮らすようになりました
ここからは大学生でもできるエコについてお話ししていきたいとおもいます
最初に言ったように私のモーニングルーティーンですね
見合わせて起床してから家を出るまでの間にしていることを考えていきましょう
まず私が朝起きてから一番にすることは洗面所に
ことです
網だけをします
その時に使っているものっていうのが
こちら
竹製の歯ブラシなんです
この歯ブラシを使っている理由というのは無駄なプラスチックを少しでも減らしたいと
いう思いからです
昨年7月からレジ袋が有料化されたことで
プラスチック問題について聞くようになったという方は結構いらっしゃると思うんです
が実際に通してプラスチックが環境によくないのかっていうことはみなさんご存知です
か
その理由は2つ一つ目が分解されないこと
て二つ目が有害物質を走ってしまうことにあります
まず1つめの分解されないことについてなんですが
果物の皮など自然に発生したゴミは何年か経った後に微生物によって分解されますが
石油などから人工的に作られたプラスチックは焼却されない限り分解に数百年以上
かかります
そして燃やされたり劣化したりというするの間に有害物質を発生させるんです
なのでこの竹の歯ブラシっていうのはとってもエコな代替品なんですね
そしてこのエコな揚げ油時につけるのはマイクロビーズ不使用の歯磨き粉です
このマイクロビーズというのは雨学校などのスクラブ
ですねこれもプラスチックの一種なんですこれらは小さすぎて気水処理を通過して自然
界
流れ出てしまうことが問題視されています
東京湾のいわしの8割からこういったプラスチックが見つかったという報告もあり
現代の私たち性じんま1週間に約クレジットカード1枚分ものプラスチックを体内に
入れてしまっているという予測も建てられています
そんなエコな歯磨きをした後は洗顔です
船外に使っている石鹸もオリーブオイルがベースでパン多い年用の
のでオーガニックの成分だけで作られていて肌にも優しいです
こういった日用品を少しでも優しいものに取り替えていくということも私たちにできる
エコな行動の一つだと思っています
セメンないでやることが終わったら次はパジャマから私服に着替えます
皆さんは普段洋服はどのようなところで購入していますか
私は昔はファストファッションというふうに言われる
可愛いくってかつやすいというところでお買い物をするのがすごく好きだったんですが
最近は新品る洋服
betta に買わなくなりました
その代わり古着屋さんで掘り出し物を見つけたりだとか
少しでもお気に入りの洋服を長く使えるような
小坪
色とを模索するようになっています
実はファッション業界っていうのは
世界で2番目に地球環境を汚染している業界なんです
ちなみに1位は明らかに環境に悪そうな石油産業です
その理由は2つ
一つ目が
化学物質が自然か a 流出していること
て二つ目があまりにも多く作られすぎて廃棄されている
洋服が多いことです
の一つ目の自然観への化学物質の流出
ファストファッションが台頭してから洋服はより安くより大量に作られるようになり
ました
でもその代わり服の材料となる面に使われる化学農薬や
皮をなめすために使われている化学薬品が生態系を壊しているんです
この画像は私が住んでいたインドネシアのジャワ島を流れる
散るタムがは
世界で最も汚染されている川の一つとして知られています
知恵多摩川の上流にある工場の68%は繊維工場でこのピンク色に染まっている彼はも
その繊維工場からの汚染水が原因です
環境団体グリーンピースがこの排水のサンプル検査を行ったところ
ある結果では pa 時14という数字が出ました
bh 14というのは本当に本当に強いとても強いアルカリ性で
増えただけでやけどしてしまうほどのものなんですね
服のコストを抑えるために安く作るために
とに基本的な排水処理するが行われずにそのまま排水が川に垂れ流されてしまうという
ことが起きているんです
当然変わり住んでいる魚は死んじゃいますし
の住民への健康位以外も不足されます
顔産業と綿花の栽培が盛んのある口にいれば
皮膚病消化器疾患がんなどの発病率が上がり
障害乳揉まれやすくなってしまっているそうです
2つ目の問題多く作られすぎて大量に廃棄されていること
日本だけで年間100万トン世界中では228国店もの洋服が毎年毎年
廃棄されています日本では完全に新品の洋服が年間で10億枚1人当たりに換算すると
約8枚もの洋服が毎年毎年何
も誰にも着られることがなく廃棄されているという現象があるんです
それを知ってから私はまず気軽に服を買うということをやめました
例えばお店ではこれ可愛いなというふうに思ったとしても実際に自分がそれをきちんと
身につけるのかというところまで本当に深く考えてから購入するようにしています
そして存在すら思い出せないクローゼットに眠っているだけの服っていうのはフリー
マーケットだったりとかを見る限りだして新たなもらいて新たにその洋服を使って
くれる人に譲るということをしています
そうやっていくうちにクローゼットの中はお気に入りの服ばっかりになって毎日服を
選ぶのが楽しくなりました
さて気概を終えたら次は朝ごはんです
食卓へ行きましょう
サボなんで皆さんは何を食べていますか
目玉焼きやベーコン牛乳トーストにバターんなどなど
動物性の食材っていうのを使っているものがかなり多くあると思います
実はこの食の西洋化が気候変動
地球温暖化に与えている影響がかなり甚大なんです
私はヴィーガンと呼ばれる食生活を始めてからかれこれ4年ほどになります
ヴィーガンというのはざっくり言うと動物性のものを食べない身につけない買わないと
いうライフスタイルのことで食に関して言うとお肉お魚乳製品卵などなどその他動物性
のものを避けています
なので私の朝ごはんはとてもシンプル
玄米と阿藤とをミサ汁煮物などなどです
なぜ私がこの食生活しているのかその理由の一つはビーガンの食生活が
球場で最もエコな食事法の一つだからです
牛肉1キロを生産するので必要な水がなんと
13000ビってるな
に対してとうもろこし1キルのと500 l ですみます
マジック鯨肉1キロに必要な餌の重さは
をなんと13キロ動物性の食品が地球にとってコスパがすごく悪いということはあ違い
ありません
牛のオナラやゲップなどの農場排気と呼ばれるようなメタンガスの発生は地球全体どう
も室効果ガスのうちの14.5%から18%を占めます
これは全世界の船飛行機
車などの運送にかかる二酸化炭素排出量である
14%よりも大きい数字なんです
このままだと私たちの未来を奪うとまで言われている気候変動
ちょ
いう音なんかの危機を緩和するために菜食
いうのはとても効果的だと世界中の様々な機関が高じています
だからといって私と同じようにヴィーガンを始めると
いうのは多くの人にとってとても難しい選択だと思うんですね
なんですがシューイチお肉を食べないだけで肉を食べているときと比べて年間で co2
を110キロも減らせて約133平方メートルの森林を守れて
107人分の飲料水を節約することができます
他にも例えば牛乳を豆乳やアーモンドミルクに変えてみたいなとか
お肉の代わりに後藤部だったり再掲しハンデも売られている大豆ミートに書いてみる
などなど本当に少しずつでもできること
私
上がります
急にすべてをエコに変えるということは本当に全然
現実的じゃないですし私自身もさせ嬲るライブクリエイターというふうに名乗っている
んですが全然できてないことはたくさんあります
あーもいるは本当に日用品ほとんどに含まれているので意識していても避けられない事
っていうのは多々ありますし
なマイタンブラー
常に持ち歩こうと思ってもカバンが小さいだとか
シンプルに家に置き忘れてしまうということも結構ありますし
去年までをとファストファッション以外方法を購入したことも
なかったですし普段購入する日用品だったり野菜だったりも絶対プラスチックに包まれ
てます
でも日々私にできることは何だろうっていう風に考えながら
一条の選択を少しでもエコにする方法をを作しています
何よりを毎日の生活の中でエコ
再来軒に楽しむことが大切だと思っています
ちなみに私がエコを意識するきっかけになったをラン打たんとあーもいるのビデオ
世界中からの声を受けて
大手食品会社さんはビデオが世に出てから2ヶ月後に
あもいるパパーもいるでもより持続可能性があるもの
森林破壊をするようなものじゃなくてちゃんと地球のことを考えているものにシフトし
ていきますというような声明を出しました
企業は私たちの声で私たちの行動で変わります
たまにはパームオイルが入っていないものを意識して購入してみようなとか
歯ブラシを買うときはこういうだけのものにしてみようなとか
鯖に行く時はマイタンブラーをててみようだとか
服を買う時も古着屋さんに行って診て掘り出し物を見つけてみよう
もう着なくなった服でも捨てるんじゃなくてフリマアプリに出してみよう
カフェラテじゃなくてソイラテをたまに頼んでみよう
朝5万くらいはお肉を控えてみよう
こういった小さな事の積み重ねてっていうのは私たち一人ひとりが行っていくことで
大きな変化につながります
とりあえずひとつからでも意識してみよう
そんな風にこの話を聞いて思っていただければ嬉しいです
ありがとうございました